I SHOULD'VE KNOWN
I COULDN'T BE A COP.
I'M SORRY
I COULDN'T MAKE YOU PROUD, DAD.
- YOU MAKE ME PROUD
EVERY DAY, SON.
- [screams]
DAD?
- YOU'RE A BRICKLEBERRY RANGER
JUST LIKE I WAS.
WHAT MORE COULD A FATHER ASK?
- DIDN'T YOU EVER
GET BORED HERE?
- IF I DID,
I'D JUST GO BEHIND A BUSH
AND MASTURBATE.
- OKAY.
- SON, BE PROUD OF YOURSELF
AND WHAT YOU ARE,
A BRICKLEBERRY
PARK RANGER.
NOW, GET OUT THERE
AND TAKE YOUR PARK BACK,
AND IF YOU NEED ME,
I'LL BE JACKING OFF
BEHIND THAT BUSH.
- YES, SIR.
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
I WAS WRONG
FOR NOT APPRECIATING MY JOB.
SURE, BEING A PARK RANGER
CAN BE BORING AND LAME
AND PUT YOU AT A HIGH RISK
FOR LYME DISEASE.
- NOW YOU GOT ME
WANTING TO QUIT.
- OH, SORRY.
FOG BRAIN.
YOU KNOW
I HAVE LYME DISEASE.
NOW, I'VE GOT A PLAN
TO GET THESE A-HOLES
OUT OF OUR PARK.
- SORRY, I WAS ZONING OUT.
I HAVE LYME DISEASE.
- WE KNOW.
WE ALL GOT LYME DISEASE.
[hard rock music]
- IT'S A GOOD THING
ETHEL KEPT THAT SIGN
FROM MIDDLE SCHOOL.
- I MUST HAVE
A SECRET ADMIRER
WHO REMEMBERED
MY BIRTHDAY.
[screams]
A CUBE OF WOLVES,
MY ONLY FEAR!
- ARE YOU SURE
THIS WILL WORK?
- YEAH, YOU'VE BEEN WEARING THEM
FOR TEN STRAIGHT DAYS.
[all coughing]
- FEELS LIKE
MY LUNGS ARE MELTING.